you know stubbing your toe hurts it's
right up there with paper cuts and
chapped lips annoying minor injuries
that hurt way more than they have any
right to but it turns out there's a good
reason why stubbing your toe hurts so
much when you stub your toe you're
slamming it with a force equal to two to
three times your body weight that's
about the same force as a karate punch
and since your toe is a tiny surface
area that force can't be spread out so
the pain stays concentrated at the point
of impact it's the same reason it hurts
so much more step on the tiny point the
end of a thumbtack and the wider blunt
end but you don't just feel the
immediate shock like when you step on a
thumbtack there's that aching throb that
comes after that's because when you stub
your toe you're actually hitting a
bundle of special nerve endings called
nociceptors they all fire at once
flaring a danger signal but some signals
travel faster than others the faster a
delta nociceptors fire the first wave of
signal which races at twenty meters per
second of thousands of densely bundled
nerve fibres and ultimately to your
brain that causes the sharp sudden pain
you feel at the moment of impact but
some nerve fibers called C nociceptors
send a slower signal at only two meters
per second so after a moment's delay the
second wave of pain signals reach your
brain that's the dull throbbing that
lingers on you can find those acceptors
all over your body from your eyes to
your bladder but they're concentrated at
the highest densities in parts of your
body that you use to explore your
environment like your fingertips and
your lips
that's why accidents like paper cuts and
chapped lips can also hurt more than
they seem like they should now your toe
isn't packed with as many nociceptors as
your fingertips but since there's not
much in the way of padding to cushion
the blow it's easy to set those
unprotected nociceptors off and that's
no coincidence
researchers suspect the pain that we
feel for mishaps like a stubbed toe
might have even saved our ancestors
lives back before antibiotics even the
tiniest cut could mean a deadly
infection and feet which were constantly
in contact with dirty bacteria-infested
surfaces were particularly vulnerable so
the people who had extra sensitive feet
might have been more careful about where
they stepped as a result they'd be less
likely to get infections I would live to
pass on their genes so the next time
that you collapse on the floor cradling
your aching toe you can thank your
great-great-great-great
great-great-great great-great
great-great grandpa for the privilege
you